was so fool podcast welcome to the
waffle
what's up full podcast with Felipe
Esparza Rodrigo Torres yeah man
and sometimes these over here in times
right here
I heard chill it back taken facts Jake
give us some question lady what's up
everybody
upcoming show this weekend March 30
Austin Texas at Paramount Theater the
show is sold out unless you come by
yourself there will be a ticket for you
yeah there's a few single tickets like
you're a solo venal like under 20
tickets left
yeah third wheel style March 31st
Atlanta Georgia at the Variety Playhouse
only 200 tickets left
so you better hurry up again there's
more than 200 ok so then hurry up man
April 5th Fayetteville Arkansas a
University of Arkansas that's a free
show hey Fayetteville anybody round
there man just show up it's a free show
nothing fancy just me by myself doing an
hour and then leaving after that April
12th to the 14th New Brunswick New
Jersey a stress factory yeah was New
Jersey for the weekends Joe uh please Oh
April 20 Albuquerque New Mexico at the
Ysleta resort
isleta resort made perfect honor Valley
Casino in Sacramento area Lincoln
California all right lots of more days
check out Philebus world.com slash tour
for all the shows dates ticket links
well Sabu chilling down how you feeling
though what's so cool man
what's all people chatter Bali a man we
should get together have dinner before
the show though saw that they did
they're gonna go to the show yeah don't
worry dogs already 80
well how about you leave my food at my
hotel room I take it you leave I go eat
it yeah man ok lingers on a food like
there are other tricks oh my god like I
just do that [ __ ] bro hey girl my uncle
my cousin
right before the girl did you take me
with with me I don't know
Oh cheap-ass huncle dog did you look at
me go you get the rest of the bees a
burrito thing alright what's the house
let's see you later
Oh dude I wouldn't hit food hit you up
the last minute Taylor the grip of them
did Flaco call it to our before the show
oh my sorry probably there's no stretch
around here for you hey you know what
killed me at the end of all the shows
wrong or you know Brazil you're alright
Foucault Flaco we're ready now at the
event man with me in my room bow but
just you I know a real Roubaix I would
just hit me and my caretaker
what's that plus one on top of getting
themselves in all of a sudden I got a
little lunchroom you didn't know that
the show was promoting city wasn't a
[ __ ] Hospital it says what dude fun
if you were to cover the hospital same
you reserved me two tickets I might be
on a hospital by then I would have done
it yeah but two hour before the show get
the [ __ ] outta here
are you teaching it to my mom I know you
won't
yeah yeah I'm making that announcement
now that if you haven't reached out to
me three days before the show I can't
help you I can't help you sorry because
it's just this inhalation I mean we
first of all we put on a hell of a show
okay and I have to say we because it was
a group effort it was like we we had a
lot of people on that show there were a
lot of people backstage and I don't like
that I mean it was because we had east
of the river opening there great and a
[ __ ] though they were eight
people on stage plus a date at nine
people and then they had like
merch person and like somebody taking
photos and it was like okay eleven
people backstage in one dressing room
like that's hard to control and they
were really cool though they were great
and they were they behaved you know like
that was their first big show at a
theater and stuff so they weren't sure
like what to do so they were very polite
and everything and J was great very
professional but yeah it was a lot that
there were a lot of moving parts to that
weekend so all these people blowing up
my phone and trying to get tickets in
the last minute including family
it's like dude this is not the time I
don't want to pick up a call
I'm already ignoring calls and emails
coming through right now and I'm trying
to like pack and get everything down
there get the merch all set like there's
a lot of stuff going on so no more do we
have all these agents providing garbage
that our agents and they well with ICM
okay but not none and not just that it's
like TV people they want to work with
you and stuff and so they want to come
but Philippe hates meeting with people
before the show hates it it throws off
your vibe more broad is a photo shoot
before the show you agree to that ahead
of time I cleared that with you you have
to be in the right spot for a suit man
he'll come in soda Papa it was his
daughter
my daughter than him he disappeared
where to find him oh my god but it's
like we told him that he's gonna bring
you a jailer Bob Solow yeah what's going
on with you luckily one of the security
guards was new who Louie was and here's
like oh he's sitting right over here how
awesome go get him please it was hard
searching for him in the dark and like
it was a cool ass last show - with him
and Russell Peters bringing you up yeah
but that was what you do I that - a bit
that was funny dog as soon as they see
them they went crazy crazy they loved
that for like he seemed like he got what
not that he didn't get love in New York
please he hosted but once they see them
in LA was like they loved all that like
[ __ ] Carlito's Way I think in Louie
goes by were to go up and bring me up in
a short Europe don't [ __ ] go crazy
yeah cuz they love gangster [ __ ] yeah
and he was like he was all dressed to
the T so was Russell dog so it was
[ __ ] sweet stuff we had a power bag
of chocolate already rule
he was cool though dog yeah Russell it's
so funny Russell always looks like he
could easily like go walk onto a yacht
and he'd be dressed appropriately yeah
like those like one like Jordan spear
users they had like wingtip fringe on
the top Justin how what 2500 we take it
up if I had to shoot bro you only see
those shoes on stage and on carpet oh
yeah yeah that like you know that's
whether he had like a brace it off
please of course he writes every
entertainer needs to write off their
clothes
there was solar on it and everybody kind
of squeezed in the room marijuana
brought to you oh my god
backyard extra by the way no no actually
really don't know that we don't smoke
yeah he's old he's old
uh but how was that stuff you liked it
which one that uh Beca extra those
joints back yeah it was good it's it
smelled like it smelled good right but I
got a long time ago bro in the broad leg
in New York Ramiro Jimmy and I'm Gabe
Roberto wrong are they asking and we
found that and that last us more like
something we got a long time ago from
your dude - okay you remember smells oh
yeah like they come back like somebody
will have that scream that seed and
they'll mix it perfectly or it'll be
that one I recognize the Sour Diesel cuz
I can't stand it but because I get so
sick up maybe I never thought that was
so these are the fourth day right before
they give it to you they put orange peel
and it's because what I said a lot you
somebody's over the back there in the
old day they took faked i but yeah for
the swag
wet and then it'll dry that one what the
apart stuff yeah cuz you can tell cuz uh
the the the branch of the marijuana leaf
it's not like a circle dude it has a
little dude man what's up for [ __ ]
now the guy from east of the river they
killed it huh yeah did not know that you
have their family yeah did and you know
what was cool I mean I'm gonna burn that
last story you were Tom but what about a
homeboy shooting don't fees
that was a bad I story and then the
second night when you told it I thought
that night did that [ __ ] [ __ ] like
was crazy crazy the like I would like I
never forget that I was doing I was
doing stand-up but under-covered I got
nobody here do we stand up I just came
on a rehab and I will go do the stand-up
with the first time I went with Ronald
no Rodney Eno's bro shout out to Rodney
man if you're in Arizona Pima Papa go
all the way he he will he was my
sidekick I didn't want to go alone he
drove with me to the gig and then I
killed it and then another time I went
with another guy named Reuben
shoutout to Reuben and then then she
could go in with different people then I
didn't stop bringing more people to the
open mind didn't became like everybody
from the project's after the open mic
because they wanted to come they weren't
doing [ __ ] right so and then one night I
was doing there was a comedy continent
at the Acapulco restaurant on Hollywood
Boulevard and labret I think or whatever
it was and I needed heads I want to win
$100
so I call it full name dovie's Rodolfo
doing yes I guess not I know you talking
about me now and I arrived I don't know
I've got a name but I last name but I
first showed up they were like 60d bro
you know in the same car hog
you know what that fool I was here we
had his brother here our young Milania
Milania Mullaly but not his brother from
his little brother and I want dog oh
yeah then that fool with that I was like
duh it's funny like like I was beginning
to do stand-up comedy these guys was to
a gang banging you know whatever but
that was cool that first for a little
while we're going the same way you know
like they never talk comedy show but
they were following me around because I
told misfired a lot comedian exciting
you have a new bro they were they got
hook they got really good I did they
liked it so they kept going every week
with me and then I won that contest then
when I was done doing the outside doing
Latino night at the Laugh Factory I
would give homeboy in the street about
to take her they were show up in a bad
back in the Boomer days yeah
but the way I ran into well before that
or the loser bro you mentioned that nice
to get almonds I just saw a fake dope 40
Tuesday
that's worse than robbing somebody by
hand by gunpoint bro you're like really
robbing them so I'm gonna show up at
like 2:00 3:00 in the morning and I will
get my own operating a little Diamond
almonds and I was where the reader blade
I will shave all the bra the brown peel
other out of the almond no cut him like
the real dope you know run I was deep up
in a little jar full of amber so and let
it sit there you know let that [ __ ] dry
then I pulled more then I put him a
little bag and then like I was served o
fools bro could know what nobody was
around
so somebody want to any bra give you two
of them so that little like I was
playing under green - that's the only
way my fake dog would not work if these
who weren't greedy right so if they want
460 I will give up 80 if they want a 20
or 40 we wanted 60 I'll give up 200
jibril wholesale if they were by the run
they'll just putting them on without by
little crackheads who didn't know what's
up don't you put in their mouths go and
right away this is my pocket eh cocaine
so do you know every time you I will do
that I was gonna do it one night because
I always come back shooting everybody
bro they're just pissed on hi Raja bro
but that dope to your house and you live
in the grand oh you live in a big
Monterey Park Whittier Rosemead do you
[ __ ] put that [ __ ] on a crack pipe
and then you [ __ ] taste peanut butter
bro anyway with a beer frig we'd wait
thank you a fake watch dude when I
[ __ ] tell you Joe they belong to
[ __ ] die Mara
I've never heard any oh my god anyways
bad now so that my brother got somebody
my brother angel he was doing that one
night but then he came he went back and
they shot my homeboy chief or they are
bro shot that food he [ __ ] to the
hideout pie little booth drove away now
to get someone so that night I was
hanging a fake dope right have 40 but
then these do showed up and everybody
end up are they real dope but this time
I guess they had their their sad
darn it out so so for said give me 40 so
I was gonna give like that I open my
hand and I put took out a gun and he
stand up give it give it give it to me
and I said all [ __ ] also he jacked you
try yeah so I couldn't let him take that
[ __ ] he find out his [ __ ] peanut
butter who shoot me right there almonds
almonds so I just but I got opportunity
I got scared I just dropped they put my
hands up and actually fell on the floor
and they when he look him down my friend
Rodolfo was coming out of the house
eating a breakfast burrito dog and I
knew that food had a [ __ ] a Colt 38
coat and a 38 gun and then I looked at
him and goes hey man shoot these fools
they're all here trying to rob us so
that fools saw that guy's good and I saw
the car and then that fool ran through
the car was the dope and some real money
that I had and I started shooting at the
[ __ ] car bro Papa like at 6:00 in the
morning
those little drunk either going to
school and [ __ ] people gonna work people
starting out the day bro we throw
[ __ ] up in two days so that food eat
a burrito go buying a burrito and
shooting while shooting multitask like
it's part of it part of his routine bro
and this part of its lifestyle so anyway
so I never forget that you know because
I could have had him killed you know for
something it was all my fault
or got yourself chaos look and again was
a cool bro hypnotized to wrassle tongue
we were little kids we were all - do you
wear in Foxcatcher that fool put on his
- his are black sweats there's [ __ ]
lucky co-chairs and the be nice Nicky
come and he was like money we took on
him he was like like the burglar
wrestler or whatever it was
oh they make me but he did larceny and
then I will go home bro and I put my
sweats on and my underwear over my
sweater like I went out [ __ ] rested
often and my brother angel he looked he
was like a dirty [ __ ]
my brother will put his fingers through
Halep he'll get a jalapeno and he'll put
our little fingernails bro all over his
fingernails in his fingertips
and they would put arrested or somebody
he'll point finger their mouth or their
eyeball my brother rested with somebody
and like he like he like you know that
is something you're waiting for somebody
to tell you my brother will fart instead
of a sandwich bag close it they run out
to your hotel that restful home being
plated mouth ah
so that dude though fees
he'll start to 500 listen man but [ __ ]
there's no more jalapeno juice in the I
know [ __ ] party and then he'll look
at me and [ __ ] you can we [ __ ]
breathing on your bad breath you know
garlic down or something yeah they're
like there'll be this black dude think
Damon I got must yes order our bro would
you put you sure those are all the moves
that you only know if you have brothers
oh absolutely especially yeah male kids
that because you don't want to hurt
nobody the real figure four leglock
fool we got Franco's to you right here
you're still regular I know now yeah oh
[ __ ] the realtor braver you're the
guy here walking around gets here maybe
the [ __ ] he does social media haha I
love Brendan Wow marry the [ __ ] his name
is running a flow bro he does social
media kinda however before back into the
funny man the old commonweal Steelers
she mad back there never had a guy like
that in an hour of material to put me up
everybody to cure me he did he was nice
to me he was good people you know like
if you like up on stage talking [ __ ]
about Tommy that's strike one
you got three first rank what mentioned
a machine anything to do with a comedy
store on stage is strike one bro
mmm because I remember there was a sign
in the back before they heard our knives
with couches
they said please no to car mixed no
jokes about smoking weed in the back oh
really
because everybody would do just about I
battled hanging out in the back smokey
the weed with our era killing the scene
people you work there yeah yeah working
with door guys still there I answer the
phones check IDs and then on the wheels
I go and do shows yeah it's fun an
absolute love it Tommy was actually the
mean J light were the last two door guys
Tommy hired Wow yeah black t-shirt a
white black t-shirts he had to have the
white one
oh really no way oh no I love Gabri
Glacia we had the white [ __ ] security
guard t-shirts you guys used to work
there yeah I never knew that oh well gee
Oh Gabriel got fired immediately oh wait
why do you find what a week you don't
want to go up the ladder he did he kept
going up as he kept doing shows on the
main room and a battery room while he
was when he was put to watch the door
you know it's funny he probably started
the thing that at the store like that
said everyone at the store does that now
oh yeah the store especially if they
like a [ __ ] better be - cuz I was block
in the main room door from the valley
room and then I think one of the just
joking people uh-huh si oh yeah yeah -
Ortiz I'm Ronnie well he walked a man
yeah you got what's up
something that is so obviously what you
want to go up at this quickfire yeah but
I watched his door oh [ __ ] ain't nobody
gonna come into my room and it was why
would I
but I have another t-shirt with my
t-shirts have to take it off when I flip
it around then they do come around
Duncan I don't know his name so tell me
got he gonna be man way to thats they're
all mine
I came to do comedy but I'm [ __ ] to
see here that [ __ ] security guard I
need to be that lady wanna go up and do
those names [ __ ] that dude I wanna go up
there [ __ ] that's the scariest thing
climb that goddamn ladder I seen that a
little rickety ass long so I lasted
longer than Gabriel no other community
that were past but never went again yeah
they just can't I don't know but just it
is that you know I come from a
background of how did you get work and
then to get paid mm-hmm I just can't be
the smartest guy in a totem pole but I
would go calling for spots but I would
always show up and get my spots and my
name is do up there find my name my
fault my eight-by-ten is in the Oh are
ya and I'll hear my new gay Bros sure
yeah like a cardigan on right yeah
everyone's photo like his his a by tears
were done by a homie so they did another
pot at the recreation park so Gabriel
like this I further there's no swimming
pool sign the one where he has braces on
yeah oh wow that will go to a sweater
mode spider face doc what's up Batman
did you guys know that what's on food on
Spotify yeah we've been waiting for this
for a while Spotify is making it easy
for you to stream this podcast and many
others like it on your mobile service
desktop or smart speakers open the app
click on the Browse channel and then
click on the podcast section take us
with you wherever you go
thanks to Spotify that's it mmm what's
up fool chillin
what's up Frank what's up much that Jose
yeah that's a bird bad baptize you yeah
your bird man and my father are so
[ __ ] close dude this is how funny it
is like the comedy community in San Jose
they all know my father they all know
bird man and like cuz my dad is like a
huge Dodgers fan like he's the only guy
in San Jose that walks all around all
Dodgers gear
everybody's all about yeah everyone
gives them weird looks and I was trying
to fight him and [ __ ] he's like no I
just love baseball but every mic he goes
to is that like a bar and like I'm a
right when I'd go I'd take him and he'd
be like oh I've been to all of these
places and Birdman was there and they
met and he's like oh I know your father
and they [ __ ] go way back
really yeah it's so [ __ ] liars that's
[ __ ] comedy I don't even know you you
knew Birdman yeah he's amazing he's kind
of like an uncle it's like it's the
weirdest thing like anytime like I'll go
do a show somewhere in Santa in San
Francisco at the Bay Area like Bermejo
just show up and I'm like oh she's going
home bro he actually Birdman is I owe
him a lot because I remember the finals
for the roast battle my dad was gonna
come down and then like his ride fell
through with his lady and Birdman just
called him was like hey I'll pick you up
we're going to LA just come with and
they drove Birdman drove my dad down a
lab routine yeah man found a ride to
give somebody else so I got to hang out
my pops during the finals and that was
like a cool thing and it was just it was
perfect and you know comedy community
man everywhere best aid can't wait to
come down maybe for for the world
premiere of taco shop bro
yeah taco shop by the way they didn't
mention this last week there's a movie
taco shop that you did years ago years
ago seven years ago yeah when I do any
of you know that people haven't really
be any projects coming out yeah I have
movies are gonna come out seven here
from there's a lot of there was some
financing felt through and all this
stuff so they never finished it but now
it's finished just got Tyler Posey for
Teen Wolf it's the guy Captain Obvious
right the guy for those Captain Obvious
oh yeah
that guy from and then the girl from
scary movies yeah
Jai Parker oh time market today Parker
Joker
hi Parker something sub tonight that
she's didn't Eric Robertson as well IRA
grab bridge well he's not old man bills
about that way with Eric Roberts yeah
that's cool the first one we've been in
once team together and then he was in
that movie like for one day
he's like he like a day player dude oh
yeah don't make money Eric Roberts bro
he's like he's a great actor and like
him he might did all those drugs back in
the day but he still focus dude like he
knows the tools of acting like he could
learn a lot with a rubber cap no lines
in the scene and he pretty much can [ __ ]
you over with no lines and even though
you can have a whole monologue and
everybody just [ __ ] you up with two
lines yeah he's good dude he's really
good like he just got a look at the
obscene and he knows okay damn bleep and
then he talked about to write down all
the words in a big ol black placards you
could he can't see but as but reading
the lines the cue card reading the lines
he really know they're good dude
like I never forget man oh we got to
talk about it but I did a movie where I
play a way a cook a waiter watch Edition
named Jose then Felipe and Erin Roberts
plays the deal is only seen the the
owner manager of a restaurant and the
scene is a woman is late she's the star
of the movie she's a witch and she the
waitress she's late and she should have
been here like hours ago and I'm
watching dishes and then he looks at me
and he goes you know he looked at the
scene in or I Robert goes um and then he
goes alright
and he goes Philippe what's up what's up
man all right we shake hands
action I think every robot walking
around he goes oh [ __ ] yeah they will
sleep it give me a [ __ ] rag let's
throw a wet rag on him and he's talking
wipe another table [ __ ] mad bro
because he had to do it she's not there
he's a manager that's what a manager
should be doing
just a real hard pissed off getting into
the [ __ ] scene cut the girl his check
he went home no direction bro direction
he didn't know he just knew that ok my
manager this [ __ ] is late I know if I
was a manager I have to work done detail
with myself cause only me Philippe and
Philippe need to be wasn't the [ __ ]
dishes so here when I started talking go
where the hell she I don't know man she
should be an hour ago I know man
and then he goes [ __ ] arrest I'm
[ __ ] scrubbing and talking [ __ ] that
she comes in and he attacks her and I
was nude kills the scene that's crazy
it's like killing two spots in one day
yeah so he killed that scene then he
after that he goes to another role
somewhere else in a different character
so he did like three movies in one night
three one day there's this documentary
that came out I came for what it was
called was literally just about like
background background characters and
stuff like who's Guzman Guzman he's
amazing but they just kind of talked
about him to where he's like they
pointed out all the movies he's been in
so there's like like 20 just actors that
are like in everything but they're
always in just like those guys those
guys it's so good but it's like you
you're like oh yeah
those guys really do steal the scene and
they don't have any and I think that's
why people love working with them cuz
they don't need any direction they just
come on they know where you go they know
how to start in and out there was a good
thing in the document where it was like
it was they were talking to Guzman and
he was just like there was like they're
like when he goes out for roles they
actually have like specifically his name
looking for this type and he's just like
that's that's me yeah do what up a
chocolate puppy man least I want to
documentary movie I said I was the
anyway at him never got to see it and
they were talking to Ethan Morales oh
yeah laughs who did all his Latino
accent to put a week to a Dominican in
New York to Puerto Ricans and then yeah
and then the Chicano sound versus the
Mexican sound
you know it flowed one into the other
was amazing I'm yeah he's badass so jig
over hold it guys James go Feeny Oh give
me some forever oh yeah you do it
Frankie
oh my god Gandolfini I love your movies
as well
slow people broken going to the [ __ ]
your podcast Frank oh yeah I have a
podcast I do it with Moses and coach T
it's called verbal violence we talk
about the rose petal then I have my own
that I'm dabbling with it's called a
village idiot
yeah I interview like my pops my mom and
like a lot of my family members right
after Rose battlin they just tell me a
bunch of crazy stories of when they were
growing up especially my will either
that the first podcast you started or
you started with a podcast this is the
first one village idiot was the one that
I just did myself and then do the other
podcast with without hanging time with
Nick yeah time I think it's called time
yeah but that web of your pockets
tripped me out with Nick started a
podcast telling her what time it is in
London and I welcome to he throws up in
London it is for 25 start looking around
man I want to know smoke what this was
man that was the podcast I started off
that oh not naked time so give you the
time it's time with Nick okay I didn't
know they told the time starting at the
store was in San Paolo but it was so
fool or so Fred how'd you get how do you
get how'd you cook what made you come on
it to look a late wouldn't you come over
here I moved here when I was 23 and I
moved here for comedy because I moved to
I lived in San Jose until Oh 17 and then
I moved to Temecula California when I
was a senior in high school so that was
like a huge culture shock for me yeah
man all white people there was like a
Border Patrol station right there so it
was like especially come from like the
city especially East Side San Jose it
was like I had to like I felt like I
couldn't like you know be myself like
had to like kind of like keep it low-key
yeah yeah it was very interesting they
had very their set views on like
Mexicans and Border Patrol is very
interesting do you a little bigger
approacheth huh yeah yep it was [ __ ]
very funny to be like yeah you guys
[ __ ] one against kids you mean like
you sent a bunch of kids back like way
to be real proud about it oh yeah that
was a big one up there fighting it yeah
it's crazy I don't know those people are
arguing that that you know you got the
people like whatever like build a wall
go back to Mexico then you got the other
food fight for the other side was people
arguing brother then I said oh nothing
much just [ __ ] you it's all policy
that's [ __ ] calm and you have people
tip you over there yeah I know white
people I pay more taxes than you guys
make yes I think you just wanted to sell
tickets out oh yeah bro a hit album came
out yeah well he cares you know use down
you know I mean at least he went over
there I think the idea is that the
protests will fuel the policy you know
try to get in it's Congress people's
ears and and try to get them to push the
agenda but protests these days are
really sad I can't my friend
well it's multiple there are multiple
things going what unity that we know
would like for the civil riot you knew
was still a right the legislation was
trying they were trying to pass
legislation for the civil rights things
all fragmented yeah it's very very
interesting and it's always like my
white friend who's comes out to me he's
like you know the March I'm like now you
can go the March almost a home cuz I
don't wanna get in trouble oh no that's
when they tell you you're barred nah bro
if I go March it'll brutality we need
more white people to March a how are you
white people march for us we'll stay
home people and then you got get beat up
for us you know then people people know
this awful white people getting beat up
for messing it on TV we're gonna put a
stop to this this ends now
yeah but you really really want to
approach it for us Mascis you stay the
front lines will be in the back quite
frankly he's got a beat up first man
people just kind of protest at the
voting booth dude yeah I mean that's
really what it is representation to
statewide than you know just gotta go on
the road man and people always talk
about we're gonna do more political Joe
Broz I want to start tickets but a blue
comedian bro I don't give a [ __ ] no I
mean I I don't give a [ __ ] but you know
what can I do I'm one man yeah it's also
like you know P I've always struggle
with that to where it's like don't like
someone had told me that like you kind
of beaten people on the head with one
subject knows like you know what you're
right and it's like you the people come
out because they want to have fun right
that's all thing it's like because if
you start doing like super political
comedy like you alienate one half yeah
well you have an agenda and you have
like a nail that's where it's bad poke
fun at both sides now let's be fun yeah
has to be fun but have to be funny you
know right but for me I got a bit tired
like what just calling will do it I
haven't [ __ ] laugh Horace I don't
want to be thought provoking where I'm
going
like trying to change the world I just
want to make people laugh if y'all like
[ __ ] homeboy [ __ ] Bill Maher and
[ __ ] oh yeah whenever I see I remember
something cool now but that damn great
but it's also you get to see like once
you do that kind of comedy all the time
you just have that set audience right
right and then it's like there's kind of
like the people like that watch like Fox
views it's like their followers they
just agree with everything that comes
out of the tunnel like when I went with
Bert Kreischer to Indianapolis and they
had like like Klan members came out like
not like cuz they're like fans Bert oh
well I guess they were but they just
happen to be Klan members but like well
you could just tell kit the way they
carry themselves like just the way they
laughed at certain jokes yeah yeah um
but like and I I remember like looking
at him and I was like oh [ __ ] like I was
kind of scared and then after the show
they came up to me and they were like
you were so funny we loved you blah blah
blah and they like made Mexican jokes
and stuff and I was like oh you guys
like it was like it was such a weird
thing for me because I was like oh yeah
I don't know how to like take this you
know they were Klan members oh yeah and
also like certain like certain people
hold like you can kind of tell like way
certain people carry themselves you're
like oh yeah you're very very much like
like that we're just fine dirty no they
were very clean dear Jeff Sessions is
gonna get that wootz hang out yeah it's
crazy I don't know what's gonna happen
to it cuz Martin shkreli they the
government took all the stuff in there
it's up to him I think he has to decide
whether it's gonna go back to Wu Tang or
if they're gonna try to action it off or
what looting sold it though right yeah
it was this rare album that that guy
Martin shkreli the guy who raised the
price but that uh AIDS drug and raised
the price yeah he he was just put in
prison for like really there
for tax issues and fraud and yeah like
last week yeah so um he had all they
seize this assets and everything cuz
they're trying to make whole some of
these people who lost money and one of
them is this rare will take whoo tang
out and the Carter five yeah that's
crazy right yes tons of money yeah
that's because we'll raid the pill from
60 bucks or $75 oh yeah and then he
bought all the things he couldn't buy
when he was a kid there's a poster boy
though they're getting yeah it was fraud
I think more proving a point
don't ever go down this road are you
gonna end up like this yeah and I think
that there there is a definitely an axe
to grind with the guy like no I think
the judge made the comments that were
made we're just like kind of more
personal you know like you're kind of
scum of the earth sort of thing into the
final statement yeah Wow that's that's
like what man that bill cost maybe $60
with $75 and that wasn't even what he
went down for by the way yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] them County Jail prices are like
five runners like a speedo Harrow we're
broke we'll call it $200 of prison you
know out here was $10 you must really
want to get high yeah so what so you
moved out to Temecula what up yo what
made you come to LA to do the comedy she
start offers I started in Temecula at
the Pechanga comedy club which was just
all yeah all very just you know older
white people and it was very interesting
to stand up there and then headliners
from the store would come and do that
Club and then yeah yep
si Trevino was there and he him and
Hasty's Trejo were the ones that told me
that I should move to Los Angeles to try
to get job at the store and then that's
when I did and then I get job the store
started helping out with Moses the roast
battle and then both
start a truth battle huh it was Moses in
real battle and then it grow battery
from vendetta go right I know he's from
most of San Diego remembers from LA
Moses cool bro Moses super cool I went
where I like telling a story matter I
have one one to go by but I don't do my
but I wanted um I I need a bud son I
know I would like I knew it I told
myself wow if I looked at long hair
Comedy Store do a band they put it put
me up so I called up the Comedy Store
and now lay and I told him if I could do
a guest spot in La Jolla
he's like a 2009 bro and I did I didn't
think I had it like that but I did call
the Comedy Store yeah he Liza slash
fingers I think his headlining and it's
okay you could do five minutes so when I
get there I told I saw our Eliza and she
was eating her tomorrow and I said Wow
of course you gonna put me up this is
Molly
so meter cheese now yeah we were talking
and she she the fan and then I went up I
went up some other aging so I went up at
the girl then um I made not Moses at the
doorman the doorman there and didn't
have all the money no they have all the
money but I didn't I couldn't break a
hundred or something then he'll really
cool about it he said just get me later
good but I don't know what I'm gonna
come back to the Comedy Store here la
jolla so whatever you know so I pretty
much that was cool [ __ ] I come back to
do a short the Comedy Store main room
then I see him at the comedy store main
room door guy oh [ __ ] I know you are you
know yeah and I think I owe you money
and I took it all out and I give it off
to him whatever I had for the notes
wedding business always already bro I
thought I'd never saw you again I never
forgot about you I'm so sorry and I give
all his cash right there oh yeah yeah
pleasant note why yeah but that was cool
but I know that he started that I know
that him and the other guy robbing that
was dark when you never doing the roast
battle he started off small huh yeah it
was a tea room it was a little just an
open mic
and then it was like a segment that they
would do in the middle of the open mic
and I got to the point where everyone
would come to see the battle and then
everyone would come and watch it and
then they would leave afterwards so if
you got fooled did you stand up after
that you would get up on stage and
everyone would be gone so then they
realize they're like alright so let's
start doing the battles at the end of
the mic and then I got to a point where
just regular people started showing up
and then all of the comics were there
and then I got to a point where like we
had a full audience like of people that
were just had heard about the show and
then we had to stop doing names out of a
bucket cuz like it gets to a point where
like some kid would put his name in the
bucket get pulled and be doing stand-up
in front of like a sold-out crowd
I never done stand-up before yeah so we
had to start like booking it and then it
just it just turned into like a crazy
thing well is about the Rose battle it
was that it was all people never knew
mhm so with your comics pretty much
didn't know how to roast no so you
really have to [ __ ] you're right it
looks happy it helped him write better
mm-hmm
because you know you get a rose battle
with people like me and open wrote the
[ __ ] real life without thinking
about it not that good wrong well you
see amateurs you know do it and he
somebody'll get better and that's a more
[ __ ] you put your funny bro oh
yeah you think in Guam Guam Felix yeah
superheroes the door yeah like somebody
like that you know like ain't nobody
gonna cut this guy a break you know but
the Rose battle helped him well forget
no Araya t he's done I think he did like
six battles and I remember the first few
battles he would like always come up
dressed up with something and it was oil
so funny
and then he would like do jokes and
sometimes the jokes wouldn't hit but
then the more battles he's done now he's
like he's a contender like his his jokes
have finally like it matched his ability
and now when he goes in battles it's
just it's always at least going to be a
great battle because then it gets to a
point where it's like certain kids go up
in battle and then it's like alright one
person easily just got whooped but then
it gets to a point where it's like if
it's a good battle on both sides and no
one really loses because they're both
showcasing how great they are like
there's this girl Joe you know short
lady right yeah yeah yeah she's good
she's great there's another girl named
damnit um I'm gonna she's in a
wheelchair
she lost her legs oh my god a Daniel
Perez she battled as kid named Joey arel
who's got cerebral palsy
no yeah cerebral palsy and he's confined
to a wheelchair yeah no parking that day
yeah all the spots taken two of the best
battles two of the best battles I've
ever seen like they were just saying the
most crazy stuff about each other and
they're both like handicaps so like
everyone said everyone didn't know how
to react because they were just like oh
my god like I don't know if I should
laugh at this or not like waka flocka
flame was there and he was just mouth
open not knowing what to do
like Joe said they call they call her a
cow because she's already lost lost her
calves it was something like that dude
it was great
her claim to fame by the way was she was
on prices right and Shana she won a
treadmill yeah she accidentally got her
legs cut off by a bus in San Francisco I
think yeah she's super funny that she's
down here no yep that was very funny
yeah when did the roast general coming
in sue the show well he was kind of cool
cuz Jeff came in I think about maybe it
was hot yeah but a year and a half yeah
cuz one of his friends was battling and
he came in he saw it and then like him
and Moses and Braille talked and then
they were like all right and he was very
like he was very like let it just kind
of grow so for like a while it was just
kind of like we kind of just figured
things out changed a few things like
made a little more streamlined because
when he came and it was super just raw
and literally oh was that with a wave
bro the way it was out of control
yeah the wave was insane back then the
beginning the way with crazy bro
something you people just going to see
the wave with what the [ __ ] they gonna
do next
oh yeah what's the way the waves Jamar
Jeremiah walk in and the real hunter
the gags they would do in between
wielders articulate there was some there
was some famous ones like there was the
one it was like right after it was like
ran after one of the terrorist attacks
like a bombing the next day they came in
and they did a joke about it and then it
was just like someone they did like the
bomb effects and they had like props of
fake limbs and just stuff it was
ridiculous because like the audience
like they didn't laugh for like a second
and then they all just started dying
because they realized what it was and
then the big dumb show with brains but
oh my god there was one one of them like
had to drink the one of them drank out
of a plunger Jeremiah Watkins shaved his
pubes on national TV some of the best
stuff okay so wait a minute so did this
go did this ever get pitched as a TV
show or become it was it was was he do
it as a special like what was the no
Comedy Central Roast bad or was like a
series or was it just like a one those
two seasons and then they just did a
third see they did a the like a little
internet first we did it on the internet
like we did like periscope and stuff we
didn't get YouTube videos cuz we just
didn't want it to be lit the way Moses
kind of said it in the beginning he was
like we're like the foot you know we're
here but we're not here and that's kind
of how we'd kind of like approached it
and I think that's what also helped kind
of get the the word out and get people
to come because they're like have you
heard of this thing it was very word of
mouth when it first started did Moses
get to be part of the production mm-hmm
they him a battle and roster but all
about it no I don't think they were
bought out they were a lot of people
were trying to get the show when it
first came out like I know like Netflix
was looking at it like an HBO and a
bunch of other people and stuff so that
was also the crazy thing was like there
was a time where like all of these
executives and like Hollywood people
were coming and just watching and then
it's like I'm up there bombing my ass
off on like just doing a set you know
order like losing a battle or like
winning one and then like someone sees
me it's just crazy spot they come in
there man cuz somebody told them but
they're clueless are what to do with the
absolutely so somebody else comes in oh
okay we'll do it that way that's no
Hollywood word yes they just they'll see
okay
this is great but I don't know what to
do with it or I don't know what to do
with you I can't do [ __ ] my ring I think
the way they did they just did like a
britain version and it was not a
tournament it was every mate yeah yeah
it wasn't a tournament it was just like
you know they changed the format and I
think that was the best way to do it w
funny all the British just kept up
Scotland Yard's huh half the audience
would be like what are these references
already have the American audience man
Chuck and fish and chips at me I don't
know if that's it hey what's up ER by
the vape exhale Evo is a high-end way
plus bong combo double J's name hi time
number one desktop vaporizer my
listeners get 10% off and a vape exhale
Evo Evo Evo vaporizer and all the other
vape exhale product by using promo code
F ool that's full at vape exhale calm
there is nothing else out there like Evo
get big bang for your buck with Evo it
takes way less herb to get you there the
taste is phenomenal it can be used with
both flour and concentrates very exhale
CEO Sabo Shan is a former stuntman and
backup dancer that now uses cannabis in
his Brazilian Jujitsu practice SIBO is a
huge advocate for normalizing cannabis
use in today's society use promo code
foo and babe exhale calm we try this
thing last week and it was good
ah yeah here to give it to Frank
Castillo is the whole reason I showed up
today
Oh whatever father did we keep
what is this though beep that's the whip
for it if you want to use this one or
you use this one but here's the actual
heat unit yeah so we put one of these in
here yes Oh scientific and [ __ ] do you
want to use the whip or you want exist
already in here yeah or you could put
concentrates in these little glass yeah
they put the oil in doing our little
babe yeah it's one of the cleanest heads
you can ever get make some sort of
sounds like little musical notes or
somebody here to do some bong rips did
you tour with Bert Kreischer I saw that
I saw that one of his um one of his
deals in Annapolis yeah yeah
wasn't he toured with um I'm really
lucky because of the rose petal I've
gotten a tour for like Rogen's taking me
out Bert's taking me out we've got an
open for Tom yeah Justin look took me
out ran is easy was it with more create
more of kaykai people at Joe Rogan Bert
Kreischer you know I was so surprised
that how many like Mexicans came out for
Rogen is kind of blew my mind I was like
oh okay and he was like yeah you know
he's like they [ __ ] love me I was
like oh that's great yeah it was just
kind of cool seeing the different kind
of audiences everyone has but also it
was cool to see like people that were
actually fans of me like I didn't
realize like how cool rosebud was I
still very much think myself is just
like a young
coming up especially working the door so
whenever I go somewhere new and
someone's like I loved you on rows
battler I loved you on this I'm always
like oh [ __ ] that's crazy they're like
where can you see you I'm like when we
checking IDs that was also the other
weird moment where it was like you know
working the door like especially at the
store everyone's such big comedy fan so
I was like when I'd worked the door to
be like a sold-out night I'd be checking
IDs and like at least 20 people would
recognize me and that was a great
feeling but it also be like I gotta like
start doing something like I got like I
should really start making moves and you
start to hate your Comedy Store shirt I
wear that on TV it was great
I saw you before when I saw you in the
YouTube videos and the roof better but
they wanna I saw you on TV
mmm I was like oh man well they're gonna
put your foot another Oh get another
latina ha ha ha yeah you brought the
mariachi's mm and I don't pay that [ __ ]
and it goes hell yeah I like when you
said that but I also thought about so
because whatever Last Comic Standing be
much I put up in yah-yah-yah they don't
know our culture bro like yeah it seemed
there were just mariachis bro that's
what they said they're like we want to
put money on cheese out for you I was
like I was like I was like I don't know
how I feel about that I was like if you
put a big Mexican flag behind me then
yes yes fine and they're like all right
cool cuz my grandfather watched it and
my grandfather like came from Mexico and
like he was his whole thing was like you
know his American dream was like
everyone gets a job buys a house lives
stable and stuff so like when I told my
was gonna do comedy he did not [ __ ] with
that at all like it was bad he was not
little kid he didn't get it at all but
then once he saw me on TV and saw me
doing it and then he saw like the flag
and all this stuff like he didn't
understand like he was lost in
translation but he understood the
importance of it so then like I remember
like it was like he was on his deathbed
and he was just like are you still doing
stand-up and I was like yes and he was
like good it was like the last thing he
ever said to me
that's cool yeah it was crazy and people
try to hit you on a Mexican [ __ ] on the
Roasters like I mean you know like drunk
Tory [ __ ] I mean sometimes but it's also
like it's what they work with yeah
I always feel that when white people
rose like white people wrote in you in a
safe environment like that Valley room
you know Joe Rogan's right there oli
white comments are right there they
could easily go for the Mexican
derogatory joke but in the real Rose
bought in a parking lot where they might
get stucked in the face go that route
that's why white people always have an
advantage at a roast better on TV
because they could get racist without
getting punched in the face yeah yeah
but in real life Rose battle they will
never go there yeah because they're
afraid of that south to the base ha ha
but you know what but that were Mexicans
and black people have an advantage of
rose battles we will go there oh
absolutely we will call you a white
[ __ ] right away yeah
but but then and get the laughs put on
TV when we come on like that comes out
angry it's tough it's tough right then
so they do it come on call the clear
white [ __ ]
yeah oh we got angry Mexican you gotta
it when it's on TV it's like you got a
you can easily go for the easy joke but
then you also gotta like challenge
yourself and go for the tougher joke or
write the better joke you don't I mean
like I mean even if you looked at all
the jokes I can did against man through
bouchard like I called him a rapist like
a million times when he's not and he
just is a good-looking guy yeah so that
was kind of like an easy way to but it's
like you just kind of got to write
better jokes cuz I think you can oh man
for the low-hanging that guy Rafi me
about the show so yeah the social just
blew up right there and went under the
ground and came out of the washroom and
a [ __ ] social just ended without the
funniest joke ever
Mikey could never come back with that
[ __ ] Mike Lawrence is a beast when he
that was the thing when he roasted
Ralphie he could have made easy fat
jokes easy low-hanging fruit but you
look at that battle and you'd like dude
he had some of the best jokes I mean
rest in peace Ralphie maybe we love
death the hardest part about your
divorce was taking out that ring
he had one where he was Joe well for me
just call him a hat going 40 yeah he did
he had one joke against Robbie he was
like man I can't I'm gonna butcher it
but he was just like calling you fats
you know yeah you know I can't even
remember I'm not gonna butcher it but he
had some jokes just against Ralphie that
were like this is like a moment that
people will always remember I mean yeah
well I think also because I think when
you have somebody more famous I like the
mixing up with a famous person season's
comic and the you know not amateurs but
the newer comics because those seasoned
comics might come in not even really
trying not thinking that they have to
prepare I mean a little cocky I can hang
I can hang I can handle this you know
I'm not afraid of these guys aren't even
experienced but it's not you know these
guys they're hungry to beat this
professional right they got it something
yeah they have a lot to lose you know
and you know I know like and they're
like oh comment and let the old comics
they're not old but the successful ones
you know it could be a young 30 year old
25 year old selling our seats he's
successful
I don't give a [ __ ] that guy's 22 if
he's selling out theaters he put he's up
there with him with Martin Lawrence to
me like he's like he's beyond like
Angela Johnson when she started blowing
up and now other guy
Molina John Molina Molina I guess for
he's so low to pocket shows and I in the
parking Cleveland when I was there I
shot one yeah man and but you put them
up I like like I was saying now you put
like one of those guys against a young
little like this I was saying our young
comic who wants to just roast
[ __ ] that little young fool
gonna come up with better jokes mm-hmm
that's not what I'm gonna say but that
boat
I was like trying to talk I was trying
to remember that Ralphie made you I was
like oh oh yeah yeah I'm hi so what's up
fool to give that a regular yeah bro now
now yeah but do their social media bro I
mean how do they pass people now cuz you
stuff showcase your form it see in the
past well man I did what nine showcases
now it's it's it's a really good system
at the store four-door guys like Adam II
get is is really doing a really great
job when it comes to door guys cousin
said because before it was just like you
had Monday potluck and your development
spots and development spots are just
whatever they toss you on in the bringer
shows or whatever independent producers
they have and now it's like you get to
open up the or shows during the week and
then you also get to open up the main
room shows during the week and you get
more development spots and you get
Monday it's just like a spot on a show
that's all that means they're also gonna
watch you stuff like that and then
Carter stole shows every twice a year
about Adam has a showcase for the door
guys which means all the door guys go up
and then he passes you from that so that
means you so you know every year you're
gonna at least showcase twice so I mean
it's a better system when we didn't used
to have that so that's one of the main
reasons why I still work there cuz it's
like if I continuing work there I still
get to do all this development and do
all these spots and I don't have to
worry about like not working there not
being a priority or not being having it
like having more of a tougher chance of
getting passed cuz it's like if you
don't work there then you have to go
through the regular system which is just
like Adam pick a showcase yeah so it's
like it's beneficial for me to work
there now plus it's like you know I get
to go on the road when I do and you know
and you got to remember that not
everybody's getting not all these door
guys are getting picked to go on the
road and that's your personality off
stage and how you're gonna because it's
not all about how funny you are
come but the point where you go back to
the door the other guy like you you had
a horrible time over there
you got started out the story yeah what
happened but it was good but that KKK
boy you got a story for them exactly how
are those first theatres I'm like but
you go from [ __ ] Hagen [ __ ] I'm
sharing one one meal at Danny's to
eating good Russell Peters getting a
watch a watch it for me right now
especially these past two years it's
been a really weird it's not weird but
it's it's interesting for me because
it's like I still you know I still have
to have I still have to have a job I
still have to pay bills and stuff and
but I also get to live this life Haste's
yeah I get the taste I get to see what
it's like you know and I'm like okay if
you work hard you can do it this way you
know any man like seeing how Joe and
Jess and I can all Burt and all those
guys do it it's like oh okay like I just
got a [ __ ] work hard and like write
funny [ __ ] yeah work smart too way Joe
Rogan podcast it's like being on Oprah
oh you're gonna sell dimes bro I'm gonna
sell [ __ ] desert brought to a [ __ ]
cow moose yeah bit of it yeah I was on
right after Roswell and that was like
that ended up doing more for me than
winning Rose panel is well I got more
followers from that Rogen's insane I
think Rogen's like the new Carson in a
sense like yeah like Oprah that yeah
that's the couch rent like so like I
mean any show I go to there's always
someone who's like they know me from
rose-petal but they always they've seen
me on Rogen so it's like that's and
they're fat the word of beanie or they
could beat me up and they all want to
smoke weed afterwards which is great
yeah I'm kind of tired of people telling
me they got the best weed
you don't bro I come lengua short when
you like you know when you cover
California and you
epilator you coming from the major
leagues bro back to the [ __ ] to the
minor leagues there Oh 100%
like I thought some people you mean
apologize right before the you used to
the Cali she remembers all we got this
is all we get every time I go and travel
somewhere new there's always someone
who's like and I was just like I don't
know any weeds and was like I hope yeah
I'm like oh sweet this is perfect
Colorado had great weed Indianapolis
mice are all happy but have a happy
Colorado Colorado was insane I spent
like 60 bucks and I got over half an
ounce it was insane I was just getting
lit the whole [ __ ] time dude Naples
had the best bud that I've smoked on the
road and years where were you in a
Colorado he did hotel with a condor I
stayed with a friend I had friends out
there and they were like right in the
heart of downtown and like her boyfriend
worked at a dispensary so we just hung
out got stoned he showed me all around
will you working with it I was working
with Burt yeah didn't get your hotel you
wouldn't want us to be friends I just
want to stay with my friends yeah most
the time like I like hotels and stuff
but I'm real weird like I would much
rather crash on my friend's couch and
just hang out and like go out to dinner
I'm such a I'm sorry like some people
like hanging out the hotel room and I
like that too but it's also like I like
going out and like looking at you it's
like yeah I never travel so I go to
other all the door guy but what happens
bro like like a pretty sure like so we
welcome to you one day a brand new two
shoes are hopeful for you okay oh yeah
they've already done that thing yeah oh
really yes we'll brought my truck that's
funny man it's funny I remember one of
my favorite like days change in the
marquee Ross has his picture it was the
day before the rose-petal finals it was
the last day before the final
and I didn't have anyone to cover my
shift so I had to work it and I had to
change the marquee so I would I had to
change the marquee the day before I went
into the finals so Ross has a picture of
me changing the marquee and then across
the street there's the marquee with like
my name on it and like the finals going
on and he was like oh this is hilarious
it was a great great picture yeah so but
you probably get you probably go out
more than other door guys right like on
the road with these guys you probably
get picked more yeah the only pick a
good Mexican bro yeah no I
yeah most time well it's also like I was
it's you know just because you become a
door guy that's not the only reason
people take you out you start to be like
like you said you have to be personal I
think yeah it's not the biggest a big
part it doesn't matter how funny you are
and it doesn't matter like how much you
kiss this guy's ass or whatever they're
gonna choose the person who's easier to
hang out with on the rim that's really
what stays out of the way but the step
are told a lot of me stories it's that
was the thing as like some like that's
why I always try to tell like some of
the other door guys I was just like you
know just like talk to them you know and
that's a lot of us are like a lot of the
door guys sometimes are just nervous cuz
it's like you know it's still [ __ ]
like Rogen or but it's you know you just
kind of start talking them and then yeah
it's you know just being easy to hang
out with you know I try to be as chill
and loki's pop don't be be nice like I
didn't know him from heaven or hell but
I thought I saw him buddy what's up man
yeah I know you were yeah I I greet
everybody bro every time an you Latino
if you don't greet me when I'm there I'm
remember you're wack you know I'm the
same way that's so funny Latino they're
amongst a crowd of blacks and whites and
if you don't say what's up to me I'm
never gonna say oh man it's so fun I
still have such a weird tendencies like
that like round
Am I I should let them Galveston yeah
I'm the same way
yeah I go I get like but a lot of a lot
of people like also hate you know like
those communities Mexican comedians who
are alternative like there's a guy named
Ed Galvez you know PI he's doing his
[ __ ] on his side
but I'm pretty sure another people
people my like oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
trying to be white but you know you're
not trying to be white he just didn't
grow up like girls dawg he didn't grow
up in the hood
that's his [ __ ] doc I put his sugar bro
he's down for us he's just a just cause
they're saying hello yeah you know a
little hat [ __ ] what's up a exactly
instead of thing he over there with a
white [ __ ] that's some he like
that dawg
that's some I struggle with a lot
because I grew up in East Side San Jose
but I didn't I don't sound like my
cousins I like them at all so when I
moved to Temecula where would that be
put busted yeah people were just like um
you know they're like oh oh you're like
Mexican but not really like some people
just you know there's still Mexican
there just raised different where if you
look like Canelo or you look like Tyson
you gotta be down I'll put a shirt
matter if she were to go down even like
if a person didn't grew up in our hood
I'm pretty sure he'll be the first
[ __ ] got to step up hard mmm so
when I was much time I'm being heckled
in Florida and I thought I was the only
masking up there right some little black
pool is flipping me off and I told him
oh you want to fingers up your ass okay
I see I thought you wanted one up your
ass cuz you'll flipping me off so that
well I wanna it so you want to fingers
up your ass then everybody started
laughing because how many you want going
like that and he came charging at me bro
like a wild man and when I were three
believers stood over white corn yo you
can stay back homie there are little
pockets of all that you know bro like
we're happy my captain oh I forgot to
say thank you for suggesting that place
to uh to get married yeah me and my girl
are we're gonna get we rented that place
where it's a great spot I love it
doesn't need a deck yeah and it'll be a
good tax right of you to that stuff also
the money goes to the Arts one of the
main reasons we did it man anybody out
there buddy I want to get married man
Eagle Rock it's the Eagle Rock arts I
think it's called Eagle Rock Art Center
yeah boy educated by Tommy cheeseburger
yeah I think we're gonna do it in an out
truck yeah yeah we were thinking I was
thinking about a truck what are bein
friends but I know some people that show
up have a vegan taco stand
ooh yeah shout out to organic sourly no
they don't do catering anymore but plant
food for people to have food for the
people baby knows by the way they made
the Bombers birria and whenever they
have brought tamales what am I like
Somali jackfruit but the recipe is all
the same cuz the guys from Guadalajara
and he said this is my family recipe did
you taste any of it no oh yeah what's in
that room for hours so that but they had
it on some warming trays it was good and
east of the river came in and ate
everybody ate they loved it he stole the
really only one of those people was
vegan brought loved it I never um
Frankie he was the rapper to you guys
man when you first started Hollywood and
that you say you jump into anything you
wanna do bro when I working at Waldo's
comedy station at wherever Johnny
Sanchez
I met Willie Barcena I'm Harlow the
Oscar this before Latino night some
[ __ ] bro convinced me to join
his comedy group
improv improv group improv group role
and will meet every Saturday bro
and Oliver will be dressed like we're
dueling a cat burglar
they were just in black all the time in
there it goes I didn't want to dress
like thank oh they're all idiots
but no it was funny but we were really
practicing sketches in the park with a
bunch of homeless people bro and I was
embarrassed bro cause I'm like oh yeah
I'm on shy I'm gonna stand up but I'm
pretty getting to the Nerdist and uh but
ii do like perform in front of another
performer I'm not wasn't ready right and
no and that fool named killer me wrong
name the group name you know that you
have yeah you probably can what a day
was Oliver's travels we were the
Hollywood's kids those skits like that's
great that's a great improv oh my god
everybody was crazy one of the guys that
was in our group his claim to fame was
he was their first cop that got killed
at Terminator 2 ah that's a great credit
man reddit never tuxedo or whatever oh
yeah yes I do know yes you know what
walking so weird he was here but three
other crazy guys oh my god are you sure
that just I sure you just weren't like
it like they weren't just practicing for
the dinner show you showed up to like a
ding dong practice they all might just
you they were all just schizophrenic
yeah but yeah like they're on the verge
of craziness man the ding dong show one
of the guys they got with an American
bhiwani bro
what what are the guys you ever talk to
dombarris
ask him in the 19 in the late in the
early 2000 late 90s there was a story
about a kid that was molested when he
was like 12 or 11 years old by a man and
then later on he was molested again bro
like the
they drugged them hidden homies and a
safe with him and then this fool called
him up and told him that I'm yeah man
thinking about you let's meet up
somewhere and he got the guy to admit my
left to him as a 12 year old and then
ever an adult on tape and a whole
residence [ __ ] and they did a [ __ ]
story about him and they had a picture
here with a ding dong oh my you had a
ding dong show but but now he would even
know the guy was working with but
together was arrested for meditation
with a Rodino so that's crazy the gala
show never had a problem
real nice got to hang out with a show or
[ __ ] yeah I've had some of the best
like working late at night in the ORS
which I'm potluck Donald go up tonight
at the end of the night and we just I've
had some like those have just been some
of the most memorable nights we're just
seeing Don get into trouble or just see
him [ __ ] with the crowd or like him
doing like the band at the end of the
night I did this one a few nights were
like I've gotten so hammered that I'm
like wow what happened like my friend
will text me pictures of me just with my
shirt off playing guitar in the band I'm
like oh my god it's a it's a good old
time I take him down the back I don't
know if you were there and Dom Barrett
had brand new beau and he told somebody
to hold it don't break it first when he
walked away man he he didn't walk away
far enough to hear it fall it fell it
broke dude we had no beau
that's the worst when you're trying to
get stone known has a lighter or someone
breaks the ball so many people now want
to get into a comedy show just because
they have weed huh
yeah that's the biggest thing as people
in the right way yeah they're just like
I get some we can give this to I I've
had Shaffir does this we're on his
podcast he'll do this thing called give
a give a door guy and ugh he'll like
give and ugh door door guy program is
what he calls it so many times
I remember like working at the store and
just be chillin and someone will be like
here you go and just give me weed I'm
like what the [ __ ] and they're just like
re says hello I'm like oh my God thank
you so much our shop here but yeah
people always try to go and sneak in the
back and smoke weed because that's where
everyone hangs out smoke weed well so
with that new Red Room the back bar yeah
yeah it's uh it's like the private
headliners bar wouldn't that we'll put
it up I'd open up I think about a year
ago maybe it's pretty sweet it's nice
Chappell loves it he'll going like you
know just chill in the back and we rent
it out and it's also nice cuz like no
one you know the security usually keeps
it pretty tight and doesn't let anyone
else go back there so who got to go back
there headliners and then just like you
know their guests paid regulars
employees and then like if someone big
comes back they usually like shut it
down and make sure no one else goes back
there you know they want to keep it free
you guys doing you know hang out and
smoke weed and chill ripped it out like
sometimes I think when he does like his
specials he'll like ran out the back and
just to make sure no one else exactly
but also like cuz dude like working
there like people just sneak back there
like it's crazy like open likers people
have fans like I've just been walking
back there and some guy just like walked
back and I'm like hey and they'll just
be talking like Bill burr I'm like I was
this like bill birnes friend they're
like no he just walked back here I'm
like get the [ __ ] out here some kid just
like oh my god I just want like I just
walked in the back and all of my heroes
were there I just pulled they want they
feel they have a right to walk in there
yeah you know him yeah yeah well I mean
I guess the best is to be undetected
yeah yeah I was on people maybe why the
officials just totally open maker 100%
what I learn yeah yeah that's the that's
the one thing is like that's one thing I
like the stores they if there's room in
the back they'll still let comics come
in and watch because that's you know the
whole thing of the store is it's still
kind of an artist colony where young
comics can go and still do stand-up
although now with the open mics there's
like a hundred and twenty people signing
up for 16 spots every week
people who woke up and decided I'm funny
huh mm-hmm to tell people how tell us
because we have some listeners yeah the
process these days of how to start in
comedy because a lot of people hit up
Felipe asking for all like I don't know
how to start we try to explain the open
mic system but every clubs different
well I think if you're trying to go to
the comedy store for your first time
don't do that that's like the worst
thing you could possibly know more the
customer pay yeah exactly come as a
customer pay hang out watch it watch the
open mic see what it is because what
people will do is people come and sign
up for the open mic and you get to if
you get picked you get to go up in front
of the you know coordinator and it's
like that's the first time he sees you
and he'll kind of you know either
remember you as being funny or remember
you as not being funny and not want to
put you up yeah so it's like first
impressions are always big hit up all
the mics you can like right yeah I mean
like everyone's always afraid to do the
work and the work is sitting down and
writing you know what I mean how much
should you come with with your very
first open mic if you get chosen or you
want your hair you get chosen three
minutes there's only it's a two minute
light but just have like a few jokes and
also because a lot of it is like dimer
the first like for me was like I'm
pretty shy so like the first five years
was still me just getting confident
enough in myself and then it took it
took me winning rows battle be like oh I
am funny and it might not be the jokes
at first it might be your performance
because it's still talking in front of
people oh that's awesome
it's still just talking in front of
people so it's like you know be prepared
to fail prepare to suck because if
you're not sucking you're not doing a
good job but you'll get to a point where
you're just better you know but also
constantly keep working getting better
going to Mike's the more times you hit
the stage the better you will just be so
it's like no matter you know everyone's
always like I'm so scared to get into
that first one but it's like now you
just got to do the first one and then
you're gonna eat it and then I'm like
okay this is what this feels like
and then you just constantly keep doing
it and don't bring anybody you know
don't bring anybody don't tell anybody
he's only buddy for a while it's a big
bad with a little bit
can we smoke this here is this thing
about the vapor just like it's not like
burnin legally watch I rewatched blood
and blood out oh my god he broke it down
and he basically American me and and
blood and blood out at the same movie
the same screen born in half torn in
half because the original American the
original American me before I was
American me before a blood and out they
were like a whole oh my soul I was just
almost took the one side of version of
the other Mexican version like the
gospel yeah yeah 100 different Gospels I
had a joke about how I was like blood
and blood out and American me was like
the first and old test or the new an Old
Testament because I think it ended up
being 3 in some hours what it would have
been like a 6 hour movie blood and blood
I was cut down to it three and half
hours like six hour it was a such a
great movie and it was produced by
Disney yeah really Taylor Hepburn for
Disney no ever like movie with character
dopey sleepy but really it was such a
good movie I mean and I made my fiancee
watch it and she was just like all right
and like I love that shot caller was
great but American meat like my dad like
we just quote meet American meat and
blood and blood out all the time that
was like I remember I remember like
being a kid being a kid and like all of
my family sitting down to watch American
me I think I'm gonna introduce Isaac to
blood in blood out
oh absolutely soon it's not hardcore
like mercury now with that knife goes
that way Syria well bro that's crazy
well him having sex with her the first
time to it's over yeah yeah I'll just
turn her over
I remember I was talking to my cousin
and my cousin's been to prison and I was
talking to him and this is how like I
guess like ignorant I was about it but I
was just like oh that's so funny they
just had like an Asian guy in a Mexican
gang and I was like it's just poor
casting he's like no that's how what
they had like multiracial people and
gangs back then I was like really he was
like yea there was this dude named green
eyes when I was in prison and he was
just a black guy and it was wrong with
us Mexicans and ever when he first
showed up I was like what the [ __ ]
this guy and they're like no he's he's
cool he's fine he's with us and they're
like oh and I was like oh and then I
realize like yeah black guys can also be
in this game and I was like oh that's
hilarious
yeah Felipe well the the project's where
he grew up everybody was mixed with your
black and Mexican yeah blacks and
Mexicans that one game yeah and when you
know the guys in prison were it was the
Mexicans mm-hmm I didn't go to a site oh
yeah yeah that was my cousin said the
hardest part about him going to prison
was that he had to pick you know I mean
because he was like he grew up with his
best friend being a black guy you know
what I mean
that was his best friend his whole life
so when he went to prison it was so
tough for him like not hang out with
black people or to be like you know just
only be with like Mexicans and stuff so
then when he got out he actually was
like not talking to his friend at all
and stuff so his friend was like what
the [ __ ] man then he was like oh [ __ ] so
you had to like change yeah change
mentality yeah man
so what you got one show you got coming
up I'm actually gonna be in Tokyo for
the roast battle out there they have
like a yeah they have like a small
little have a small little room and then
they have a bunch of other rooms that
I'm gonna be doing stand-up at so it's
my first time out of the country so I'm
really excited and then I got some shows
around here but that's like the biggest
one that's coming up who you going with
that's just me jokey oh yeah a roast
battle they're having me go out do judge
and stuff it's not part of the Comedy
Central and it's just like they had like
there's a room they do a roast bad like
people from Europe and all that come out
and do it I guess they have a big expat
community yeah I had no idea when you
going through that middle of May give me
a
giant flying robots shirt I will double
extra-large alright you don't fly robot
is yeah that's the any suckle yes cycle
yeah yeah another theme song robot
and then I think I'm in Indianapolis and
August for a festival and I mean you can
catch me on Frank Castillo dot-com I
think is my website I'm so high right
now but I post all my dates on my
Instagram Frank Casteel Frank Castillo
what's your process when you're writing
for the Rose Bowl like I have a certain
process that's different than now I turn
in like a serial killer I like I like
studying yeah I study them like I listen
to podcasts I talk to them I interview
them like asking questions stuff and I
put their pictures on my wall and then
I'll write out my premises and then I'll
do like looks like jokes and then I'll
do like like thing and then I'll slowly
move them as I like write newer things
and like make it out and stuff I worked
on a show of funny that the president
when I was working on a show called
domme I working with you know a tour
with doing it oh yeah we followed out
Dominican couple and a Puerto Rican
couple and they were gonna or both honey
oh we're gonna marry each other
mhm so we got to know the whole family
could not the English at the end of the
way they were gonna roast him at the
wedding
mm-hmm both part of the show it was
called a wedding zinger when he's
English so I got to know the whole
family secrets no not to a bunch of
noise coconut roast everybody and now
and then she we got you marrow but I
don't know the girls I hold over the
guys and we had all the photos and when
we're looking for jokes all right what
do we got our Juanita right here she'll
go that bad you know
at first you throw anything no honey we
got something funny and then we had
everybody broke but I wrote some good
[ __ ] but then the guy altered I listened
he got caught cheating bro doing a
[ __ ] show during the very broad to
rope that football get caught cheating
because that will win a motorcycle with
another
those chicks follow Tory [ __ ] she
threw that pool in the car while he was
an abortive none of that made it to that
it was like really happening behind this
today I think they were thinking of not
getting married right that was a good
did she ever find out and then though
the girls getting married she had a
sister that was a same age bro from
another lady so weird you know because a
dad was there and she was getting
married his daughters getting married
but he has another daughter who the same
age and then that girl has two other
daughter so they have like she had oh
she had a sister since Alabama
yeah the two older sisters and a sister
who could be a twin from another
stepsister who the same age as her there
are two half-sister yeah so when I was
up there we got we got Carlos Figueroa
right here wow I'm surprised in here we
have here his daughters right here his
daughter from was other lady and you
know the baby mamas daughters over there
and I'm his son
and everybody I broke up I forgot the
player Johnny Appleseed over here but
there were what my ass Johnny FSC so I
was although I have to roast it bro but
they were expecting that eh yeah but the
show didn't get picked up but the frost
was the same we put their photos up get
wrote a bunch of joke or a bunch of
other DC which was funny but would you
the company said they approve your jokes
or you decided what jokes are good well
for the finals they were like they gave
us like some extra cash they're like if
you because also some of the people
there like had just this is the first
time they did roast battle so they were
like they wanted to make sure the show
was good so like if you have anyone
helping you if you want people to help
you like here's some extra money to give
to them so that's badass right there
yeah that was smart for them I think and
so I had my boys Pat Barker Jay light
and Dan Nolan and we all sat together
and we just like we all like worked and
wrote and like I dictated like I was
like this is what I think we should do
and then like we put it together and
then at the finals they had to send them
all of our jokes and just they can
approve them and then they were like you
know which ones are good which ones are
not not which was a good witch or not
but what we can say what we can't say it
was more illegal
yes though deforming anybody yeah the
funniest thing that happened was during
the finals remember the SNL thing
happened with that writer who made it
from the Trump's kid yeah and then she
got fired yeah
so that happened and my boy Dan Nolan is
like hey you should do this joke that I
wrote and I looked at him I was like uh
I don't know man he was like no you
should do this joke because I think it's
it's perfect and I was like right and I
did it and it was the best joke and a
Republican blog picked it up and wrote
about it because they said they're like
this is how you write a joke they're
like this is how it like this is how you
write a joke making fun of Trump without
making fun of Trump and then like they
compared the two they'd like SNL jokin
in this joke and the joke that he wrote
was Anna's Anika pass for Trump she's
got the body of Ivanka the brains of
Melania and her womb is barren and it's
just you know just to play on words and
stuff but they like loved it and like
after that the counties unser came down
they're like all right if you guys can
please no more bear and Trump jokes and
we're just like oh I was like are you
saying we can't make those jokes or that
like we shouldn't they're like we're
just asking you guys politely to not and
we're like oh okay
I was like oh [ __ ] that's crazy we yeah
man I was like hey I got one in that's
great
coming up bro dinner lunch no I was
gonna start a podcast this opee do ya
just post all the questions everybody
asks me into the Castro pickle people
have been asking in the road people keep
asking French a lot of Castro we're just
so busy
hahaha but also do rubbers though I know
I got we got another rabbit
I wanted to give another shout out to
vape exhale
that's ba p e ex h a la cama cama code
fool fol at checkout and you can get 10%
off
that's just like a bong vaporizer in one
like doesn't exist anywhere else
I think the check it was one man deep
exhale it's good you're not even making
good on it contact hi Megan you mean
Emma Emma before you go bro I love Mike
Tyson mysteries it's the best so great
right [ __ ] hilarious bad so far Mike
Tyson knows you have to act he's acting
like himself he stays [ __ ] that I will
say the medium bro
[ __ ] that you have said in meetings all
right he goes good food like this bad
they're talking to him and you know
they're saved you forsake it no sequel
all right oh yeah all right then he goes
give a cell you talk about this outside
your matter of the [ __ ] out of here
he said yeah I didn't understand one
word of that [ __ ] so let's I propose we
get the [ __ ] out sometimes in meetings
when I hear these people with buzzwords
or like we need some ramp up time over
in a circle back and all these buzzwords
it is you know corporate words and stuff
and Philippe I could just see this
glossed over look like I'm not paying
attention because they lost me with all
this speak like all the stuff they're
used to saying around the office or in
emails to other agents and stuff they'll
use it in the meetings he hates meetings
that don't go anywhere
meetings they mean easier just to pour
drinks afterward I talk about nothing
yeah he didn't want any of that so all
these people try to get in their foot in
the door with like let's hang out let's
have a drink like that he doesn't do any
of that so he's not going to meet with
you and then when you are his agent he
still doesn't want to hang out and have
dinner or lunch or drinks unless it's
going to lead to something do we really
need to discuss something but it's like
watch it watching Mike Tyson
industries is like what there's not
waste there's not waste your percentage
out of here on me lately like like um
like what we're talking we're talking
before the show with our fraser-smith I
sold out four shows at the noble theater
nice 6,500 people a lay represented
Hellion and now saw all these
[ __ ] hitting me up roll all
we've been big fans UTA oh so what are
they trying to just swoop bro Oh Chi
trying to go trying to sign you know
agents don't help people who need the
help
no of course not I know you're doing
yeah no 100% but they should it but I
got a manager after Rosa this how crazy
was getting a manager for me like it was
like confetti was falling they handed me
the trophy and then I got like a tap on
my shoulder yeah they're like we
represent we'll have a meeting we'll
give you guys a call is like oh you
don't have my number they're like we'll
get it and they just left and I was like
this is [ __ ] creepy yeah and then a
bunch of people hit me up and then yeah
but agents are just different they're
tougher to get ahold of and yeah yeah
manager come on Z but once you get an
agent thump the manager unless you
really I mean honestly yeah it's not to
say that but once you get an agent you
know hand you across the board they
still the big agencies like they're
gonna handle your special appearance
they're gonna handle your acting your
your development they're gonna have your
voice over they're gonna handle you
wanna write something yeah man be a best
friend yeah I mean if some people do
need direction and do need that manager
but if you really already know what
direction you want to go just go for
them I just need a young age yeah I love
my manager he's great yeah yeah agents
are tough but they will not touch you
until you're making a certain amount of
money exactly yeah and then they start
hearing stuff and oh we have been we
have been fans since the beginning
he was yeah I've uh Freddy sodas old
manager oh yeah yeah
with worthy putters there Jeff Chetty Oh
Jeff's Shetty fools
okay oh yeah that's what you get we're
gonna be out this week yeah but ever
almost where am I going back to huh
lovely live right now in Oxnard knowing
what's not in West Nyack in October
what's nobody law but that wave going in
[ __ ] enjoy coke wall know what I'm
saying [ __ ] it's time you guys
stop checking out the yeah man podcast
episode 37 with Elvis called dad's from
the transplants wonderful I give a
little rat about people getting passed
for doing social media haha well one
thing you've got to work on guys their
social media gamer that's club and
social media let me tell you something
right now [ __ ]
grab that [ __ ] phone it's up in the
[ __ ] head with it what's up water
snow show right there get the sentence
but take it
what's up fool little children right
here Frank Casteel check out my dad
Frank Casteel on Instagram
please so here Esparza getting greatest
overall podcast Dara Shikoh Fox I'm
gonna call girls school that's nice
movie so sexy girls to the ex was a
little
[Music]